cursing at children flashing a coaster
actor Tim Allen may play Santa Claus but
co-star Casey Wilson says he's anything
but Jolly Casey Wilson acted alongside
Tim Allen in the pilot episode of the
Santa Clauses a Disney plus series that
serves as a sequel to Alan's three the
Santa Claus movies on the podcast sesh
Wilson described alen as quote so fuing
rude she discussed filming a scene with
the star where Santa comes down a
chimney and Wilson's character proceeds
to throw things at him she explained he
goes over to the producer who is
standing 4T from me and goes and I hear
him he goes you got to tell her to stop
stepping on my lines the producer turns
to me with horror on his face and has to
walk one foot to me and he goes um Tim
would ask that you stop stepping on his
lines as if that wasn't enough Wilson
said that at the end of a scene Alan
loudly proclaimed that he was leaving
and dropped his cape onto the floor for
others to pick up she concluded he's a I
will not say who said this this was
someone that I do not know perhaps in
the the crew he or she breezes past me
and just goes you're seeing him on a
good day as of this video Allan has yet
to respond to Wilson's remarks but it
would be in line with other behind
the-scenes stories that have come out
regarding the actor over the years for a
show about Santa Claus as on Disney plus
the Santa Clauses seems to find itself
mired in controversy constantly viewers
were annoyed by one joke in particular
in season 1 which was clearly inspired
by a popular conservative talking point
saying Merry Christmas to all has
suddenly become problematic now Alan is
once again in the hot seat and it's his
alleged Behavior while filming that's
put him in the line of fire it shouldn't
exactly be news that Alan has a short
fuse in a 2021 interview on The Kelly
Clarkson show Allan spoke about an
incident on the set of the Santa Claus 2
where they were shooting a scene
involving a bunch of children a couple
of the kids began acting up and
preventing them from getting the shot
they needed as Alan put it the kids said
one more word and I let out the loudest
F bomb and I turned around and there
were 12 children it looked like you'd
ripped their legs off their Santa is
just scream the FB he added that he
recognized his mistake and even though
Disney tried to do damage control what
was done was done but alen's
unprofessional behavior allegedly goes
back much further to his home
improvement days in the 1990s Pamela
Anderson wrote about Alan in her Memoir
love Pamela recalling an incident on the
set of Home Improvement where he
allegedly flashed his genitalia at her
variety published and exerpt about the
incident from the book in which Anderson
wrose he opened his robe and flashed me
quickly completely naked underneath he
said it was only fair because he had
seen me naked now we're even I laughed
uncomfortably Allan denied the incident
in a statement of variety these
accusations may explain why Hollywood
doesn't really cast Allan anymore
outside of his main franchises like the
Santa Claus with season 2 of the Disney
plus series wrapped and seeing how it
hasn't been renewed for season 3 quite
yet it's possible that Casey Wilson's
story as well as others concerning Alan
could vinced Disney to drop the show
like a hot piece of coal Merry Christmas
[Music]
Sarah